[Music]
hey i want to circle back for a second
because kids activities john
is um
one of the things that is a budget
buster in our world and um
sometimes i get um
roundly and wrongly criticized by saying
no children should ever have any
activity dave ramsey's too cheap you
should never if you're following dave
ramsey plan you should never have a
child in any kind of extracurricular
activity that costs money ever under any
circumstances that's just not true i do
not say that i've never said that ever
in 30 years of doing this
um
what i have attempted to do is what we
did in the ramsey household is to use
some common sense
when it comes to
kids activities
if a little league baseball is funded
but the college fund isn't
ding ding
wrong right well he might play college
on a scholarship he might not too
she might not too
um statistically speaking probably won't
vary statistically speaking um and and
if they go to college the chances that
they play pro
are
one percent
of the ncaa athletes go pro
one
freaking percent so how do we translate
that statistics probably not your kid
not not your kid probably not your kids
not your kid right so um you know let's
think this through then what are
extracurricular activities for
our piano lessons dance lessons
um
little league sports of all kinds uh
cheerleading
competitions and lessons
nothing evil inherently about any of
them but like so many things when they
go to an extreme and they violate common
sense
many times it's more about the adults
than the kids and you bust your budget
doing it yeah i mean i've got a whole
section in this new book about that
about
over the last 25 30 years there's this
weird switch kids used to be furniture
or pets at best right i've got to make
sure we run this household and over the
last 25 30 years they've turned into the
epicenter of the household
and in the name of nurturing it well it
started out in the name of nurturing and
it's become in the name of propping up
my ego because i'm not happy at work i'm
not happy in my marriage i'm not happy
i'm disconnected from a church my
community
but if you find yourself waking up
thinking about little league baseball
plays you you probably got a problem if
you wake up thinking if you're an adult
an adult i'm gonna pitch this guy in
this weekend or okay if my daughter can
pull this trick off that she can get
this and
we've gone way overboard man and we're
taking we've we've taken the fun and the
way that the parents treat the referees
tell you that it's bananas bananas i've
got friends who are
you know i worked in college i got
friends who are
trainers in college in universities
across the country telling me they've
got athletes who are 18 coming with
overuse joint injuries in their
shoulders knees and hips that they see
in elderly populations because these
kids at from age four
are getting personalized coaches and
specialized this you're only going to
play this you're playing year round not
doing other sports not just running and
playing and being a kid there's so much
psychology about the importance of just
letting your kids play that's how they
figure stuff out it's how they stretch
their imagination they develop neural
connections all that stuff happens but
man when they feel like they're in a job
a kid cannot prop up and hold up i'm
getting fired about this i'm sorry they
they are do not have the strength to
hold up a mom or a dad's self-esteem
they do not have the strength to hold up
a home and the number of calls i get on
my show about
my dad yelling at a kid for his athletic
performance or
all of that stuff breeds insanity stop
it stop it man let your kids play
and
your treasure's where your heart is
always
if you if you see that you're spending
so much on this
that it feels out of whack you know why
it feels that way because it's probably
out of whack right
it's probably out of control that's
right now our kids did cheerleading and
took cheerleading coaching my kids play
a little bit and my kids played rec
sports of all kinds i talked about
daniel playing hockey a minute ago
we spend money on other things around
that kind of a thing but we were under
no illusion that our child was going to
make a living cheerleading
and i'm under every illusion that if i
feel my blood pressure boiling over the
performance of a nine-year-old the
problem is not the nine-year-old the
problem is me
you know i it's uh one reason i dropped
my ut tickets
because i my blood pressure was boiling
over someone else is 18 years old over
teenagers these are teenagers with 120
000 people threatening to kill them
that's right that's exactly right over
the use of a pig skin yeah that's right
you know what i've lost my rabid mind
i'm with you and i'm i'm a football fan
but i had i was i spent a bazillion
dollars to go watch the game to be angry
let's see right and i thought i'm just
stupid or the opposite to how my week
fulfilled because a group of
teenagers rallied up and won a game yeah
and if you're a tennessee fan that never
happens
not careful now now see what you did
yeah i see what you did there but yeah
we
and again so like
sports is travel sports illegal no is
sports illegal no is you know is
spending money on violin lessons no
music is great music is good for the
brain development that's right i spend
money on that stuff for my kids and uh
you know that's fine but my
my wife took piano lessons and get this
you might be a hillbilly if
harmonical lesson there you go okay
so and we have the harmonica
so um we've we have used it a time or
two and some family jokes beyond belief
but uh giving her a hard time but she
could play neither yeah
now
neither but she can deal with you and i
think
i think all the lessons she got growing
up are all came together for a purpose
god doesn't waste anything dave nothing
least in god's economy nothing nothing's
wasted oh i'm touched
touched so i mean that's the thing so i
um let me yeah so here's the thing if
you are advancing their
maturity
their ability to move into adulthood
fine but if you're if you're playing if
they're playing for you
which you can tell that with some of the
symptoms you get laid out that's a
problem and one of the ways you can tell
that is the money will tell you because
the money gets out of control what
you're freaking spending
on the travel
on the uh lessons on the specialization
relative to your overall budget so now
again if you're if you got 20 million
dollars and you want to spend a hundred
thousand dollars on your kid to go do
whatever that's fine like that that's
fine but even that you got to look at it
and go this is a kid i just dropped 100k
on a sport they're never going to use
or on a music lesson they're really not
going to develop into a lot of parents
have stopped asking their kids what do
you want to do what do i do
one of the one of my worst parenting
moments that has become one of my
favorite
i would come home i was exhausted when i
was a dean of students i would plop on
the couch and i would watch the astros
game and i would try to instead of going
out and playing ball with my son i tried
to get him to watch it with me going out
and being with him i'd say hey let's
watch together and then one day he said
hey dad this is just six-year-old
innocence said hey daddy do you love me
as much as the astros
and that's when we turned it off and
canceled it and then this is just a few
weeks ago
he came and said called a family meeting
i thought oh no what is happening he's
12. he's going to be saying hey mom dad
we need to talk
but he said
i i don't know how y'all are gonna
feel about this but i'm interested in
not playing sport x this year i would
love to try out for the school play
i've never been prouder of a 12 year old
which tells us we redeemed that and said
give him some language what are some
things you're interested in let's try
stuff let's expand it we're not going to
no one's canning out scholarships for 12
year olds let's let's let these kids go
back to playing and let's let us do the
hard work of getting our identity in
other places man i wish it was not true
but they are giving out scholarships for
12 years they probably yeah
they shouldn't be that's right yeah it's
uh we're getting there but the thing is
this guys
you know you need to
money in your life
where you're putting it and the ratios
and where you're putting it will speak
to you
as a symptom of an underlying problem
and where you feel anger is also a
symptom it's a of an underlying that's
right it's a signal yeah or great fear
or anxiety that's right